here's kind of a half form thought I'm
going to throw out there so I keep
forgetting that the second part of June
is coming out this year and part of the
reason I keep forgetting was because
while I thought the first one was
perfectly fine I was not bold over the
way so many other people were and I
think I may have hit on part of why I've
hit a point where extreme loyalty to the
source material or you know taking
what's in the book and putting it on the
screen doesn't impress me anymore like
it used to I was there when Lord of the
Rings hit that felt Monumental but we're
in a time post Harry Potter post
Twilight post Hunger Games where extreme
loyalty to a source material has become
the norm so if all you do is take the
thing I know and put it on screen I'm
like yep yep that's kind of what I
expected I wonder if that's part of why
I'm I'm still holding on to hope for
comic book movies because they tend to
be based off years of material so while
I can go o I recognize that I don't
necessarily know what's going to show up
that I'll recognize